more live local now many of us are
dreaming big as the mega millions
jackpot continues to grow thank you so
much for staying with us here at 4 30
i'm christian cassidy and i'm vanessa
murphy that jackpot holding strong at
1.1 billion dollars billion with a b
okay well we are not part of the lottery
here in nevada there are several places
you can get a ticket prim about 40 miles
south of las vegas and over in arizona
about 30 miles from the hoover dam and
into kingman photojournalist tim zitlow
and i drove to arizona's last stop where
we found many looking for their billion
dollar opportunity
arizona's last stop off the 93 was
packed with customers hoping to buy that
winning ticket of 1.1 billion dollars
some looking forward to the cash value
of
648.2 million dollars it is
life-changing there's charitable
foundations that you can donate to which
i would probably do
actually i would do because it's too
much money most of the customers i spoke
with were from nevada hoping for some
relief at the grand canyon state after
hearing about the long lottery lines at
prim that at the nevada california
border oh no
traffic and waiting in line and all of
that no
this is much easier i've done this
before we just take it one person at a
time we try to help everybody that we
can we even print tickets ahead of time
so people don't have to wait in line
this store has four machines for cash
purchases and three machines for debit
cards options rhonda field says helped
her get in and out of the store fast we
wait until it gets to a certain amount
as far as on the mega but we're here all
the time buying scratch tickets aside
from helping family and friends rise
financially many lotto dreamers said
they would pay it forward if they win
the grand prize i need just a little bit
to help the people in the world
especially the ukrainian people some say
the location is worth the drive from las
vegas after learning about the 2021
winner a resident from north las vegas
according to a store employee took home
more than 650 thousand dollars
all right so today we want to show you
where we went to talk to all those
people for our story so we drove from
las vegas all the way down to arizona's
last stop and that is over in white
hills arizona and as you can see here in
the map there are several locations that
you can also stop along the way between
arizona's last stop all the way down to
kingman arizona and of course the other
popular destination is a location over
in prim which is at the nevada
california state line now odds of
winning the mega millions are slim it's
actually one in 303 million but if one
it would be the second largest prize in
the 20-year history of the mega millions
now back in 2018 the winner took home
1.5 billion dollars now that ticket was
sold in south carolina and the remain
and it remains the world's largest
lottery prize ever won on a single
ticket how about that vanessa